I do a lot of things today and the first
things that I do today are not about my
work because I think of myself first I
had made as a husband and a father and
those are my highest duties the ones I
take most seriously maybe that's part of
my Christianity I don't know but those
my highest duties on my duty to my
neighborhood my duty to be a good
citizen is is high was the head of a Boy
Scout Troop with a mission to inner-city
new haven for many many years I think
the reason I did that wasn't much for
the fun of it did i'm not going to claim
that i enjoyed it that much i probably
didn't but it seemed to me or something
that ought to be doing i think really
that was a big part of it but what i do
otherwise is i am a law professor and
i'm a writer i teach and i right
teaching to me is fundamental to human
experience we all teach every day by
example whether we want to or not I
teach I admit piccoli arcane's up here I
teach Lloyd great future lawyers I don't
know if there's a valuable social
enterprise or not I certainly hope that
it is but in the work that I've done is
a scholar and I've been right ive been a
legal scholar for a quarter century now
in the work that I've done as legal
scholar I'm particularly interested in
the ways that law can and should be used
to constrain power I'm a lot less
interested in what we should use law as
I said before to force people to ER to
keep them from doing I'm interested in
how to use law to constrain power public
or private that really is to me quite
important because I think that so much
human misery comes when power or the
public or private power cannot be
resistant when there's no force to stand
against it and I believe in those forces
of many different kinds that stand
against power that motivates me as a
legal scholar it motivates me as a
commentator of public issues it also
motivates me in another life i'm also a
novelist i write novels i've written two
bestselling novels and my novels I'm
often confronting people the novels are
I guess you'd call them thrillers and
yet within the thriller structure what
strikes me as important as how to
constrain
power I don't mean how is a bad guy
going to lose the good guy going to win
I mean to see how bad guys are created
in a sense buy power unconstrained by
something inside the way it's something
inside each of us that can rise to the
surface of unexpected moments can take
advantage of not being restrained I'm
not saying I know evil people in the
world I think there are but i also think
there are a lot of people who wouldn't
seem to act the way they do if they live
in a world where they themselves had a
stronger sense of constraint of limits
on what they're able to do